his Stacey Abrams has really changed the
game here Stacey Abrams is this failed
gubernatorial candidate she lost then
she wouldn't concede then she keeps
pretending that she didn't lose and now
she's campaigning actively openly for
vice president really it's really ugly
it's an ugly thing to do doesn't look
good I mean but the the media are really
enthusiastic about her for a number of
reasons and so now the other people have
to campaign as well including people
like Gretchen Whitmer so I wouldn't be
surprised at all if the Biden campaign
has never picked up the phone talk to
her she wants to take the shot across
the bow to say hey wait a second this
isn't just Stacey Abrams running for
vice president I am running for vice
president too and she's not getting
anywhere near the coverage that Stacey
Abrams is I've wanted to get to this
article all week this is an article from
the Washington Post I think it's like 60
pages long it's a profile of Stacey
Abrams that is I'm not joking I think
it's like it's a it's novel-length
profile it Ben Washington's boast of
this failed governor candidate and what
Stacey Abrams all she's ever been as a
state rep and yet she's being talked of
as one of the most important politicians
in America just a few lines to give you
the sense of this fiction just a few
lines to give you a sense of this
propaganda the power of Stacey Abrams
despite losing the Georgia governor's
race in 2018 she has moved quickly to
political prominence right because you
you gave her political prominence she
hasn't moved quickly to it you've just
given it to her
because you wanted to pretend that you
won the race anyway will she be the vice
presidential pick for Democrats I don't
know you you guys are doing this so or
is she I should ask you why you know
boast you're the ones who are gonna pick
this kind of thing first line there's a
big buzz at the Loudermilk Convention
Center in downtown Atlanta at a
gathering called paradigm shift 2.0 when
she Stacey Abrams is finally introduced
the women shout and leaped to their feet
young women stand on chairs camera
phones fly
Abraham's who appears both amused and
slightly disturbed by the fuss over yeah
I bet she's real disturbed Stacey Abrams
hates the limelight yeah there's one
thing I know that Stacey Abrams she
hates getting attention right it's a
woman who refuses to admit that she lost
the race goes on television all the time
pretends to be the governor of Georgia
yeah no she's disturbed by the fuss over
she takes control of the chaotic scene
she takes control she's a leader I've
witnessed this level of affection for
very few political leaders in the
Democratic circles I've been in since
the 1980s yeah no you've witnessed this
level of affection for whichever one you
guys are elevating in any given moment
sure I guess you can only really elevate
one at a time but you've got you picket
you are the circle's you are the
affection and then this is this is the
best life pandemonium ensues as she
walks to the far left of the stage like
a runway supermodel I'm not gonna make
any comment about that I'm I'm just
reading The Washington Post don't you
can't trick me into making a comment
about that I'm just see the words say
it's right there she walks across the
stage like a runway supermodel stops on
a dime poses tilts her head slightly and
smiles camera flashes explode she pivots
she next pivots and walks slowly to the
center of the stage freezes there and
repeats the pose again the flashes
explode they explode there they don't
explode and cameras haven't worked that
way in a hundred years the image that
she's giving you is like it's some old
timey press conference and the guys
holding up the flash and he's got the
camera they click it in their light bulb
and the camera explodes that none of
that happened none none of what is being
described here happened except in the
imagination the fevered imagination of
the partisan operatives who pretend to
be journalists at places like the
Washington Post
that's living in fiction that's living
in fantasy that's living in delusion and
it's something that Democrats do
regularly the
trouble with that it ties right back in
to what we were talking about with the
coronavirus with a foul Qi and bargain
the trouble with that with staking all
of your credibility on this fantasy
rather than just like calling it like
you see it having a little bit of
skepticism looking at the facts and
interpreting them as accurately as you
can trouble with just pushing this
fantasy as if by merely saying certain
things you can change reality this has
been the lefts pitch going all the way
back to intellectuals like Karl Marx
right if you just change the words you
will change the reality if I call a boy
a girl then the boy really is a girl if
I say that the disease is the virus is
going to kill everybody it's gonna kill
three million people then it really will
if I say that the virus spreads in a
certain that really will if I say that
this failed gubernatorial candidate is a
runway supermodel the most important
politician and the last twenty years in
American history then that really will
be the case but it won't be but it won't
be because reality reasserts itself in
the end and that is our wonderful
conservative consolation when we
consider all those shady deals
ouchy and bargains that the left makes
[Music]
[Music]